folks we're going to do about 15 minutes
of questions and then those of us here
are going to go and have a drink with
Brian in the library I think the
temperature there is less than 35° but
we those that you have thermometers can
bring them with them and we can check it
when we get there uh so keep your
questions brief um ideally have them as
questions uh if you will and their mics
will come to you Alana what's online
thinking well so um unfortunately I can
only see questions within this
Multiverse um but we've had people uh
logging on from brington America
Kingston England Athens in Greece so all
over the world are tuned in with us this
evening um the first kind of observation
we've had and and a question to build
from it is the the globe of the universe
with the Milky Way going around the
equator is a very kind of anthropomorph
centric view of it how and I'm I'm going
to build on that you know how do we
break away from ourselves when we're
looking at all of these huge questions
where we're not in the middle of it you
know where do you kind of start with
that right well most people when they
hear that I'm a cosmologists say oh that
explains your phenomenal hairstyle um
and I'm just joking um they either do
that or they ask me their their for
their horoscope when they find out I'm
an astronomer uh but actually those two
things are related Cosmos and cosmology
and cosmetology Cosmos means beauty or
face the universe presents a face to us
and we see that and it is beautiful and
the more you know about it the more
beautiful it gets in fact the Milky Way
is actually sort of a redundant phrase
because Milky Way galaxy galaxy means
Milky Way according to my sons at least
and we we do personify things I should
point out that not all cultures perceive
the same things we do in fact the Inca
astronomers were quite Exquisite
observers of the night sky when they
look at the night sky from Chile where
we build the Simon's Observatory they
look not at the bright constellations
Virgo Gemini Aries they don't care about
the bright stars they look at the dark
Dusty globules they have their own
constellation names and some of them are
doozies there's one called the toad okay
fine there's one called The Llama but my
favorite is the umbilical cord of the
Llama imagine you go to a bar as an Inca
1400 years ago he's said what's your I'm
an umbilicus I'm an umbilicus so all
cultures do that they have different
origin stories science is attempting to
make precise An Origin
story but as Richard fan say science is
the belief in the ignorance of experts
not the wisdom not the knowledge of
experts meaning that what I say tonight
could be completely wrong as Faraday
warned and some of you out there or in
here can prove us wrong or come up with
a better more refined idea of it and
that's the goal of science science is
never settled science is an infinite
game and yes we're human beings that
play it and so it's natural to make it
appear as similar to things that we have
familiarity with as the Incas did with
the things they saw around them thank
you brother if you have questions then
uh by the way it's it's it's good that
the answers to questions are getting
Applause as well as the uh Talk itself
if you have questions do give us a wave
can I build on um so okay good uh we're
going to
go here and then later we're going to go
uh there while the microphone's going
quick question on Carl Poppa's terms
right so you talked a little bit about
difference between maths and physics and
POA says you really are going to be
trying to disprove stuff but new
theories are really cool right and
coming up with them they're beautiful is
it really the case that you're trying as
hard as you can to disprove the really
cool stuff that you're coming up with
cuz experiments to disprove things are
what you're supposed to be doing right
yeah so it it is true that it is it's
it's I won't say it's easy I'll get into
a lot of trouble for my theorist friends
some of my best friends are theorists um
and uh but to to you know predict a
theory often times it's said that a
theorist needs to be right once in her
career to have a phenomenal career an
experimentalist can be wrong once in his
career is over meaning that you you know
you can produce a supply that might
exceed demand and there might be more
than data can predict it's familiar from
things like string theory for example it
may not even be testable the predictions
are so vague and all-encompassing it's
like what poer originally was concerned
with was astrology so he used to say
that people would say uh as an
astrologer you know you go out tomorrow
and it'll be a lucky day for you what
does that mean it's not precise be
precise means rule something out not
that you accept something as being true
okay thank you uh yes yeah so you have
this idea of the inflationary Multiverse
and then the idea of the many worlds
interpretation the Multiverse in that
respect does it make sense to ask like
what space are these universes expanding
into is that even a sensible question to
ask and are the is the many worlds
Multiverse sort reconcilable with the
inflationary Multiverse okay so what
space are these things expanding into
right question so the balloon or this
beach ball kind of Mis portrays what
what's happening you can almost see this
beach ball expanding or something like
that um that is not what we believe what
what is more similar what would be a
better depiction um would be to to put
little dots on this trampoline here and
then distort it by putting the
Cannonball on it the dots would move
away in the space itself they wouldn't
expand into the third dimension they
would stay a fixed to the second
dimension of the sheep so too with our
universe our universe has galaxies and
stars embedded within it the Stars
aren't moving the galaxies are all
receding away from each other but
they're expanding in the same space
itself so it's not as if it's expanding
into another space around it although we
don't know for sure as I said there
could be literally another big bang that
happened approximately the same time ago
as our big bang in a region of this vast
four-dimensional Infinite Space that we
would then come into contact with and we
would have a microwave background which
would bear the imprint of that microwave
background and where they are touching
the intersection of two spheres in three
dimensions results in a one dimensional
or circular pattern so there are
predictions made by colleagues some of
whom are are in the UK and Canada and
elsewhere that you should look for these
patterns of circles in the sky that
would be indicative of a collision of M
of multiversal bubbles so in that sense
yes they could be in a vaster space
surrounding us but um but we we don't
want to think about it expanding into
this room but more stretching along
constant Contours that exist in
presently thank you um I think the
microphone's there
yes um if we have the electromagnetic
field and you can generate an
electromagnetic pulse then with the
scaler field is it possible to generate
a Scala pulse that's very good question
so actually I didn't describe how the
universe results in a gravitational wave
background uh due to the um due to the
fluctuations of the scalar field which
is is what the question is asking so in
inflation the scalar field has a value
just like the thermometers do at each
point in this room but then they start
to change and you can visualize that as
the value of the the field evolving in
what's called a potential and the scalar
potential here is the height above the
floor so this ball will move faster as
it traverses trading its potential
energy which is a scalar for kinetic
energy which is another scalar but it
will acquire a velocity which is a
vector if this was a Quantum ball the
ball if you zoomed in on it wouldn't
roll smoothly towards the bottom it
would Jitter back and forth and those
Quantum fluctuations would cause this
region of space to expand slightly
faster than this region of space and
that would then have pertubations in the
density of SpaceTime itself in its
curvature into those potential Wells
matter would a glomerate dark matter
first then ordinary matter and then you
would get this pattern here but you'd
also get get a reverberation of the
sheet
itself and that's the analog of a
gravitational wave so it's a very preent
question you would observe that you
would observe the fluctuations of the
scalar field effectively generating
curvature pertubations and so-called
gravitational wave or tensor
perturbations very good question we have
good questions at or we've got some
online and then I think we're going to
the I think probably the hottest spot in
the uh Theater which is right up at the
top there Al what's else is going on so
just building on that scaler field
discussion we've got a question from Les
um and uh Les is asked so if if scaler
fields are thought to have started
inflation what was the trigger point if
there was one to stop that inflation so
another phenomenal question so when I
did this demonstration with the
supercritical fluid uh there was sort of
a symmetry that would occur that would
get broken in certain spots but if I
kept if this petri dish were infinite
and size it would keep going it would
keep spawning these little fractal
remnants that have the shards that would
appear as if they're own Island
universes so what happens with
inflation and that terminates the
inflationary process is the universe is
expanding as the potential as the uh
scalar field rolls down from what's
called a false vacuum it evolves slowly
rolling picks up speed and as it's
picking up speed imagine the sheet is
expanding also and it could be expanding
faster than the speed of light as this
sheet expands eventually there's energy
that will be dissipated between the ball
rolling and the sheet almost like a
friction term that friction is the
Hubble expansion itself that would cause
eventually what's called reheating that
would then cause the universe to begin
with a bath of unimaginable hellish
temperature even hotter than here and
that would then provide the energy
necessary to spawn particle
anti-particle Pairs and spawn the matter
content of our
universe thank you while I mop up
Faraday's original uh plate um we'll
take a question up there yeah so again
just building on that uh idea of the
scaler field um you talked about how the
gravitational waves are produced is that
indicative of gravitons or is it all
Quantum particles um and also well hang
on WE we'll take one at time cuz we're
almost out of time he I think the
gentleman mentioned graviton yeah what's
what's a graviton so a graviton is one
of my top three favorite particles is is
a proton the graviton the Crouton I love
uh so A a graviton is the is the Quantum
analog of a gravitational wave the same
way a photon is the quantum mechanical
instantiation of a electromagnetic wave
so we call it that but unlike a photon
we don't know that gravit that gravitons
exist because we don't know if gravity
is a quantum Theory or a purely
classical
Theory good answer um there was a
question I think yeah yeah let's go that
way um firstly thank you for the
brilliant lecture it's really enjoyable
um when you talked about the cyclical
cosmology Theory and the idea of sort of
recombining into another big bang and
that how that could also combine with
the Multiverse Theory I was wondering if
the universe is constantly expanding at
a faster and faster rate and the only
evidence of the Big Bang came from
billions of years ago what's to say that
another big bang couldn't be happening
now within our own universe and it's
actually a sort of concentric spherical
model um so there are limits on how
spherical and how far apart the nearest
Big Bang as you say might be from us and
those limits are exceptional uh
exceeding the characteristic Horizon
size of our current universe so we don't
believe the universe has curvature on
scales shorter than the observable
universe's uh diameter which is quite
enormous and in fact three times the age
of the universe multiplied by the speed
of light because the universe is also
expanded now the question of whether or
not you could have a cyclical universe
and you could have an initiation of
Another Universe via the acceleration
that we call Dark Energy it's not clear
if dark energy is Einstein's brilliant
blunder it's not clear if it's what's
called a cosmological constant it could
be a variable constant that makes sense
it could be something that appears on
human time scales or even Galactic time
scales to be constant but is slowly
evolving that its energy will Decay and
be lost and converted to some other form
of energy namely photons and that
actually does occur in sir Roger
penrose's model of cyclic conformal
cosmology at the end of an Aon and in
the bouncing cosmological model of Paul
steinhardt and egis and Neil turo so it
is under active Pursuit
very sadly Brian we're kind of out of
time so there's a few things we need to
do firstly um life lives of Brian there
are a lot of Brians in the universe uh
some of the American uh people who do
this stuff are called Brian one of our
own Brian uh Brian Cox has narrated a a
virtual reality Guide to the universe um
we're going to be trying it out in this
theater as you mentioned a lot of
Innovations were first uh demonstrated
here including uh moving pictures uh and
color photography uh here it's not the
first time that you'll experience
virtual reality but it is a time that
you can experience it so look online if
you'd like to sit in this theater uh and
have a virtual reality exploration of
the universe narrated by our Brian then
uh you can do that now as you've noticed
this thing has not uh uh just been about
our lecturer but also about our demo
team and our herit heritage team we have
Charlotte we have Mike who's mostly been
working on the ventilation this evening
Isa and Dan I don't know if they can
come out they probably can't um but if
you can give them a round of applause
wherever they
[Applause]
are secondly the advantage of being in
the building uh and we're particularly
grateful to members and patrons that
have chosen to join us as part of this
continuation of our nearly 200e
tradition we'll continue the discussion
in the library and there is a bar there
those of you at home sort out your own
drinks but um we'll be uh we'll be there
so please join the speaker uh in in
having that continuation of the
conversation there look this is a a talk
about the Universe um many of the
principles of the universe uh were
discovered here on the way out look at
the carpet and you will see that the
patterns which farad discovered of the
uh uh field lines around a magnet are uh
recapitulated in the carpet that you'll
be walking on so look at that as you go
but also a lot of the instruments uh and
experiments that Faraday originated are
here this is a a Living Museum the Royal
Institution the items that you see in
front of you and that you see in the
cases downstairs were built in order to
explain the principles that Faraday and
others in this building elucidated about
the universe and I was delighted to note
that as Brian was uh putting together
the experiments with the demo team in
many cases the modern instruments and
the modern elements didn't work as well
as Faraday and we got I'm literally
telling the truth they brought we
brought out Faraday from this store and
they worked better than the current ones
it's very rare to get a talk that covers
the entire universe but also explains so
eloquently what the raw institution is
about I'd like to thank all of you for
coming and being part of this but please
join me in thanking our discourse
speaker Brian
Keon